dhamma tells a dog's story but behind
the scenes things allegedly got ugly in
a different way when you craft a story
about one of the world's most depraved
serial killers you can probably expect
some backlash Netflix is getting that
backlash from several directions over
their latest Based on a True Crime Story
the ever so slightly confusingly titled
Dharma monster the Jeffrey Dahmer story
starring Evan Peters as the infamous
Jeffrey Dahmer this streaming series
looks at both dharma's childhood and his
victims the details behind the killings
are sordid and stomach churning which is
why the story of the crimes have been
told and retold over and over again in
books movies and now this limited series
currently holding around a 53 critic
score and an 84 audience score on Rotten
Tomatoes Dharma is proving to be
divisive with audiences but the
production of the series was also a
struggle for some of the people involved
here's why despite the lukewarm critical
response to the show the popularity of
Netflix's Dharma series is off the
charts already the show is set a
staggering record by being the most
watched program in 60 countries and
netting around
196.2 million viewed hours according to
variety the show also generated
headlines after some viewers expressed
misgivings with Netflix tagging the
streaming show with an lgbtq tag some
viewers perceive this tag as being more
appropriate for more light-hearted
inclusive content and not shows
involving serial killers the backlash
was loud enough that Netflix ended up
removing the tag this isn't the only
negative headline to come dharma's way
although The Killers crime spree took
place more than 30 years ago some of
dharma's victims have family members who
are very much Alive Rita Isbell who was
the sister of 19 year old victim Errol
Lindsay had her statement from Jeffrey
Dahmer's trial recreated in Netflix's
show which didn't exactly sit well with
her in an essay published by Insider
Isabel shared her thoughts about the
Netflix series and the renewed notoriety
brought her a brother and her brother's
killer after watching some of the series
she says that the content bothered her
especially the moment where her impact
statement was recreated verbatim under
her real name she said I was never
contacted about the show I feel like
Netflix should have asked if we mind or
how we felt about making it they didn't
ask me anything they just did whatever
your name is Satan
I'm bad Lindsay said the recreation made
her feel like she was living the moment
all over again and the fact that she and
other victims families appear to have
got nothing out of the arrangements at
poorly with her she said I'm not money
hungry and that's what this show is
about Netflix trying to get paid it's
sad that they're just making money off
of this tragedy that's just greed on
sets not everyone was happy with the
Dharma series either one of their
production assistants on Dharma said it
was one of the worst sets they have ever
worked on according to the LA Times
production assistant Kim allsup wrote in
a now private tweet I worked on this
project and I was one of two black
people on the crew and they kept calling
me her name we both had braids she was
dark skinned and five foot ten I'm five
foot five working on this took
everything I had as I was treated
horribly in an interview at the LA Times
allsup elaborated that she hadn't
watched the series saying I just feel
like it's going to bring back too many
memories of working on it I don't want
to have these PTSD types of situations
the trailer itself gave me PTSD which is
why I ended up writing that tweet and I
didn't think that anybody was going to
read all sub also lamented that Dharma
was quote one of the worst shows that
I've ever worked on and alleged that
there were no mental health coordinators
available on set a Netflix spokesperson
told the LA Times that all crew are
provided access to free Health and
Wellness Resources including therapists
regardless it seems as if controversy
has followed this new show as almost
every step of the process even in some
ways you wouldn't expect it to turn up